we turned them into a superpower not the
other way around without us china is not
who they are today they've been for many
years they've been a superpower but they
co they go up and down quite often
because they like to control and the
people realize it doesn't work they have
a fall then they come back up and they
fool the people and they control again
and it falls it's just a very cyclical
cycle they go through but at the same
time when it comes down to
you know your president and you're going
with the your number one enemy there
isn't anybody that's close to china
russia's big but not at the level of
china right
um
how should that be handled when it comes
out again next person gets elected say
it's the santa states trump says
michelle obama whoever it's going to be
president again you're going to face
china again no question and they're
going to push the envelope again should
you double down on tariffs the way we
did before was like add another five
percent add another ten percent add
another dis
should that be our approach you have to
inflict pain
you have to discourage that kind of
behavior and that's how you do it
so uh
there's probably a host of things that
could be done
that
they wouldn't particularly like
and i think this is where negotiation
comes in
and you start to say
look this is where we are this is where
you are
uh
let's see if we can work in such a way
that we both benefit
if not
these are the things that we're not
going to be able to
to cooperate with you on
and you might find them rather
distasteful but this is the reason that
we're doing them
you know it's it's interesting you say
that we talked about this where i said
if we would have gone four more years of
pain like that to china i don't think
they could have handled it i don't think
so either yeah and you know look at
russia
now what do we do with them
we empowered them
we gave them the energy keys
um and do you think uh putin would have
gone into ukraine if we had not given
him all that power and we weren't giving
him all of this money of course not
so i mean there are consequences and we
find ourselves in difficult situations
because we do things that don't make
sense is green energy a good goal to
have renewable energy absolutely
are we ready to switch everything over
to it right now absolutely not
do we have a wealth of fossil fuels and
have we learned how to extract them in a
safe way so that we have the cleanest
air in the cleanest water since it's
been measured absolutely should we use
those things
to get where we want to get with the
renewable energy
absolutely
should we just throw them away and
create a giant chasm
and and
further the time when we'll be able to
have green energy absolutely not but
that's exactly what we've done and at
the same time empowering putin it makes
zero sense
when you don't
use your brain
when you just react to things and you
say
because my enemy or my foe
use this i don't want to use it so just
shut down the pipeline shut down all of
this stuff let's put all these
regulations in place
that's kind of the way a three-year-old
thinks
but that's on both sides though dr
carson uh not not not this blatantly
i mean when you do things that hurt the
american people right so that you can
get back
at your political adversary
you know this is this is probably one of
the most blatant examples of that that
has ever occurred is it fair to say that
to the left putin is their number one
enemy and to the right china is the
number one enemy is that a way of
putting it would you
i wouldn't simplify you know what i'm
saying angry but i i think perhaps uh on
their list of priorities that might be
the case right so so the the left uh
democrats don't want to
see russia getting stronger and they see
that as a threat and to the right maybe
it's more china
than it is uh russia i asked that
because when you put terrorists do you
remember the cfo
of huawei where the daughter was in
canada was doing business with iran and
then all of a sudden president trump
said huawei you're out and you got to
get out of here and even though maybe it
was good for us to have a third phone to
have a competitor because in the us
right now we really don't have a second
competitor on phones true truthfully
nowadays
if a person has a droid
i think you don't fully understand what
a blue text is and how much you're
screwing up group texts when you're when
you're the only person that's green
you know so i think america needed
competition but at the same time if
huawei were using it to get information
out of u.s to
take it back there i think that's also
the right move to make but but what
what what have we done
with respect to china and russia
we have driven them together yeah i
agree
and that creates an even bigger problem
no question about that so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]